let's talk about this other movie that
you're promoting right now a movie
you've already made an independent film
black bear this is quite an interesting
movie
a lot of different perspectives in this
film a lot of different ways
uh for it to be interpreted what would
you like to say about black bear
well i'd like to say that this was a
passion project
and i'm very proud of it it's a very
dark
uh you know psychologically
effed up movie and uh
but um but it features great
performances by
christopher abbott sarah gaston and um
and uh but for real it's a great movie
yeah buy it now
rent it now get your mind blown you
haven't seen anything like it
it's a it's a fascinating film and uh
the first part of the movie is sort of a
response to the i mean the second part
of the movie sort of a response to the
first part of the film
i've said too much already it's a
fascinating film
and uh i think all the posters say
it's psychologically effed up no one's
said that about a film since herbie the
love bug
so you should be proud let's not forget